COMING OFF OF A
MATTHEWS, KEEP A CLOSE EYE ON
HIM.
BACK FROM THE TWO GAME
SUSPENSION.
THEY STARTED OFF FOR NASHVILLE,
PUCK
THREE OTHER GUYS, STEAL BY
THE HERD IS TO RUN
TO THE ICE, TOP CORNER, TANNER
JEANNOT, NUMBER  THE
MIDDLE, POKE CHECK BY JOSI,
COMING IN TO HELP IS FORSBERG.
THIS TEAM IS DYING FOR  GETS
THROUGH BY THE DEFENDER THERE
SO IT DOESIT'S FREE,
HE WADES,  IS THROWING
MAN OPEN, MARNER, AND HE
ABSOLUTELY LAMBASTES
THIS ONE, SHORT SIDE, AND I
THINK, YEAHAT
THEIR GAME.
>> Willie: KNOCKDOWNS OF THWS,
NET, JAMMING IT IN, AND
GOALTENDING.
>> Willie: ANOTHER FACE-OFF WIN
FOR THE  MAPLE LEAFS, STILL
TR
FILIP FORSBERG.
HIS  BREAKS THE FRANCHISE
UP, AND AHEAD,
FORSBERG, COMING IN, HE HAS GOT
DUCHENE.
FORSBERG, REBOUND, THIS SEASON.
WHAT A SHOCK THERE IN THE
OFFENSIVE ZONE, GET POSSESSION,
ONE OF THE BEST POSSESSION
TEAMS, I THINK THIS IT.
UP THE BOARDS FOR SISSONS, TWO
ON ONE, TRENIN, HE